crisis over ukraine us allies are
negotiating for peace and preparing for
a possible war french president emmanuel
macron met with ukraine's president
yesterday and said the standoff with
russia could go on for weeks and months
at the same time nato forces hoping to
encourage russia not to invade ukraine
holding a series of war games in nearby
estonia and charlie dagetta is there
british and estonian tanks square off
against each other in a snowy wasteland
not far from the russian border
nato partners locked in a simulated
battle
with the massive russian military
escalation near ukraine sending jitters
throughout this entire region
these war games have never been more
real
if a conflict were to break out in this
region these are exactly the conditions
they'd be dealing with deep snow a
difficult terrain limited visibility
against an enemy that far outnumbers
these forces in terms of troops and
weaponry
the baltic states lie right along the
borders of russia and belarus each home
to a multinational nato battle group
american reinforcements have been
deployed to poland and romania
while moscow has sent tens of thousands
of forces to belarus part of a massive
russian military buildup
there are still hopes for a diplomatic
solution to the crisis in ukraine
but military preparations are never
based on a best-case scenario
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta lasna
estonia